en el último vídeo vimos las tablas de
multiplicar desde la tabla del 1 hasta
la tabla de 9 y me quedé sin tiempo pero
en realidad eso fue bueno porque desde
la tabla del 1 a la tabla de 9 son el
núcleo de las tablas de multiplicar y
verás que si sabes todas las tablas de
multiplicar desde la tabla del 1 a la
del 9 y sabes también multiplicarlos
entre estos desde la del 1 hasta la de 9
entonces vas a saber hacer cualquier
multiplicación pero que quiero hacer
ahora es que quiero contemplar las
tablas de multiplicar pero para 10 11 y
2 así que empecemos con la del 10 cuánto
es 10 por 0 pues súper fácil 10 por 0 o
cualquier número x 0 es igual a 0 luego
tenemos que 10 por 1 sería una vez el
número 10 así que sería igual a 10
y creo que hasta este punto para ti todo
esto es natural pero ahora cuánto es 10
por 2 se suponía que cambiara los
colores pero ya no lo hice pero bueno
cuánto es 10 por 2 sería igual a 10 más
10 que esto es igual a 20 ahora no está
cómo va a empezar a surgir un tipo de
patrón pues primero tuvimos cero luego
tuvimos 10 luego 20 entonces cuánto es
10 por 3 sería 10 más 10 es 2010 es 30
20 es lo que llevábamos anteriormente
más 10 es 30 ahora sí tú podrás decirme
cuánto es 10 por 4 10 por 4 sería 40 10
por 4 40 y si te dijera cuánto es 10 por
5 deja utilizo otro color para señalar
el 5 será igual a 50 50 entonces 10 por
cualquier cosa o cualquier número es un
número con un cero detrás de él entonces
teníamos el 5 escribimos el 5 le
agregamos
10 así que sigamos 10 por 6
tenemos el 6 y agregamos un 0 a su
derecha y así lo vamos haciendo
sucesivamente espero ya hayas visto el
patrón 10 por 8 sería igual al 80 luego
tenemos 10 por 9 igual a 90 y ahora qué
pasa si tenemos 10 por 10 esto es algo
interesante entonces 10 por 10 mejor lo
voy a escribir este 10 de un color
naranja pues como habíamos dicho
anteriormente colocamos el número
inicial y le vamos a agregar un 0 a la
derecha un 0 extra entonces 10 por 10 va
a ser igual a 100 y porque va a ser
igual a 100 pues tenemos 10 veces el
número 10
luego cuando teníamos 10 por 1 era una
vez el número 10 luego 10 por 2 igual a
20 luego 10 por 3 era 30 y finalmente
por eso llegamos a 100 es 10 veces el
número 10 por lo que ahora 10 por 11 va
a ser igual al número 11 con
pero extra igual a 110 y finalmente 10
por 12 es igual a 120 y ahora sólo por
diversión
esta fue tu tabla del 10 pero ahora que
sabes cómo va el patrón para la tabla
del 10 puede hacerlo puedes hacer lo que
sea posible pregunto cuánto es 5.732 por
10 va a ser el mismo número inicial el 5
mil 732 pero agregándole un 0 entonces y
qué pasa con la coma que estaba por aquí
bueno pues hagámoslo sencillo esto es
simplemente para poder leer dicho número
así que si la coma que teníamos por aquí
empiezas a leer los miles a parte de
dicha coma entonces ahora la coma que
estaría situada por acá nos va a ayudar
a leer nuestra cifra entonces la coma
realmente no tiene un significado tan
importante pero si te ayuda a leerlo
entonces esto se leería como 57 mil 320
5 mil 732 por 10 es igual a 57 mil 3
20 donde simplemente agregue un 0 a la
derecha y fue una sencilla
multiplicación ahora observa si
tuviéramos 50.000 por 10 el resultado
sería igual a 50.000 y esto pasa porque
es como cuando teníamos 5 por 10 sólo
que ahora en lugar de tener 5 tiene 5000
y le estás multiplicando por 10 y el
resultado entonces es igual a 50.000
pero bueno pasemos a otra cosa en
próximos vídeos voy a estar bien este
tipo de problemas o cómo resolver
problemas con este tipo de operaciones
pero bueno vayamos a la tabla del 11
cuánto es 11 por 0 súper fácil es igual
a 0 11 por 1 es igual a 11 ahora cuánto
es 11 por 23 11 más 11 y este resultado
es igual a 22 cierto
ahora si tenemos 11 por 3 es igual a 33
luego 11 por 4 es igual a 44 y creo que
aquí ya resulta ser obvio el patrón que
estaba siguiendo cuánto sería 11 por 5
sería 55 simplemente estoy repitiendo 2
veces el número porque estoy
multiplicando el 11 entonces cuánto
sería 11 por 7 pues 84 simplemente estoy
bromeando solamente hay que ir siguiendo
dicho patrón repetimos dos veces en
medio entonces será igual a 77 luego 11
por 8 utilizando otro color es igual a
88 11 por 9 es igual a 99 y ahora si me
interesa saber cuánto es 11 por 12
perdón 11 por 10 para ir siguiendo un
orden puesto me diría sería 10 dos veces
el 10 y eso sería incorrecto este patrón
de ir repitiendo el número dos ocasiones
simplemente se aplica para los números
del 1 al 9
pero qué pasa cuando llegamos a este
punto bien pues podemos pensarlo de dos
formas pues pudimos sumar 11 al 99 que
llevábamos y este resultado entonces
sería igual a 110 y voy a mostrarte
ahora cómo hacer la siguiente forma
bueno realmente espero que anteriormente
hayas visto el vídeo de cómo sumar
números de 2 dígitos como estos lo cual
nos dio 110 o bien puedes usar la
propiedad de la tabla del 10 que
teníamos que simplemente anotamos el
número y le apuntamos un cero a la
derecha que era igual a 110 ahora si
llegamos a 11 por 11 aquí lo volví a
equivocar lo voy a remarcar para que
quede claro que estamos multiplicando 11
por 11 también podemos pensarlo de
distintas formas podemos sumarle 11 a lo
que llevábamos a nuestra multiplicación
anterior lo cual nos daría un resultado
de 121
y de hecho como puedes ver ahí hay un
orden en cómo hemos ido obteniendo los
saltos múltiplos de 11 pero también lo
dejaré para futuros vídeos y entonces
finalmente llegamos a 11 x 12 lo cual
puede ser igual a 11 veces 12 o 12 veces
11 o bien puedes decir son 11 más lo que
llevábamos en la multiplicación anterior
entonces aquí tendríamos 121 más 11 y
que nos daría sería igual a 132 es
simplemente suma 121 más 11 y otra forma
en cómo puedes hacer esto es decir ok
cuánto es 10 por 12 y de 10 por 12 ya
sabíamos una técnica ponemos el 12 y le
agregamos un 0 que es igual a 120 y nos
hace falta multiplicarlo por un 12 por
11 más entonces le van a sumar 12 a 120
y llegamos de 2 distintas formas al
mismo resultado muy bien ahora pasemos a
la tabla del 12 y creo que después de
haber visto todo lo anterior estás listo
para resolver
cualquier tipo de problema que incluyan
multiplicaciones pero lo dejaré para
próximos videos ahora cuánto sería 12
por 0 será 0 12 por 112 y ahora sí
cuánto sería entonces 12 por 2 sería
igual a 24 pues 12 más 12 que llevamos
ahora sería 24 ahora 12 x no no quiere
22 lo voy a reescribir 12 por 3 sería
igual a 12 12 12 o bien igual a decir 12
por 2 más 12 para que me voy a equivocar
quiero poner 12 por 2 más 12 o bien el
24 que llevábamos más 12 de cualquier
forma estas tres son igual a 36 24 12 es
igual a 36 ahora cuánto es doce por
cuatro de igual forma le sumamos 12 a 36
y este es igual a 48 o bien puedes decir
que
es 11 por 4 que es igual a 44 como lo
vimos anteriormente y le sumas 4 más y
vamos a llegar a que es igual a 48 es
algo similar a lo que hicimos
anteriormente o bien sumarle 12 a 36 y
son dos distintas formas de llegar al
mismo resultado así que vamos a seguir
cuánto es 12 por 5 12 por 5 es igual a
60 le sumas 12 a 48 y esto es igual a 60
esta de la tabla del 12 en realidad es
la que siempre recuerdo cuando mis
cuentas no cuadran me preguntó cuántas
12 por 5 y digo a es igual a 60 y así
voy sumando y voy rectificando que
estaba en lo correcto y que mi memoria
aún funciona aunque yo sea un poco mayor
que tú quizás de repente me acuerdo y
bueno ahora cuántos serían 12 por 6
sería 72 leo 12 por 7 igual a 84 y vamos
a ir sumando los 12 de poco de 1 en unos
+ 60 y 72 luego 72 + 2 es 84 y ahora
cuánto sería 12 por 8 vamos a decir que
es igual a 96 12 por 9 le vamos a sumar
12 al 96 lo cual nos va a dar que es
igual a 108 y ahora cuánto es 12 por 10
sabíamos de lo anterior que esto es
igual a 120 o bien sumarle 12 a 108 y
llegamos al mismo resultado y cuánto es
12 por 11 es igual a 132 y 12 por 12 es
igual a 144 en general en la
multiplicación de 12 por 12 la vas a
escuchar más de lo que tú crees digamos
que tenemos no sé una docena de huevos
por otra docena de huevos y que en total
esto te daría 144 huevos
entonces 12 lo vas a escuchar en general
demasiadas veces y se importante que
recordarás dicho resultado pero bueno
hemos terminado nuestras tablas de
multiplicar y ahora esperaría que tomás
un poco de tiempo para memorizar las
haciendo quizás algunas cartas o usando
algún tipo de software que he
recomendado en mis sitios web aunque
creo que es hora de actualizarlos porque
quizás esto estás viendo este vídeo en
el año 2200 pues probablemente aún o ya
no existan esos software entonces sería
recomendable que tu buscas alguno con el
que te acomodar a si pudieras practicar
este tipo de operaciones pues te van a
servir bastante en un futuro o puedes
pedirle a tus padres que te vayan
preguntando